This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Producer Liza Yeager recently did something that will become pretty common with the next generation of kids. She asked her grandma to show her her tattoo. Can you just describe what the tattoo looks like? That's Liza. Oh, the tattoo. And that's my grandma, Carol Fischler, showing me her tattoo. It's very tiny. I think it's maybe five eighths of an inch,
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。制作人丽莎·耶格尔最近做了一件事，这在下一代孩子中将会变得相当普遍。她让奶奶把纹身给她看看。你能描述一下这个纹身看起来是什么样吗？那是丽莎。哦，这个纹身。那是我的奶奶卡罗尔·菲施勒，正在给我看她的纹身。它非常小。我觉得大概有八分之五英寸吧，
and it looks like a little hand mirror. Although, it's definitely not a hand mirror. It's a little circle, and then a line going off to the side of it, and then there's a cross over that line, because my blood type is O+. It's a tiny tattoo of her blood type, right on her ribcage and just under her left arm. Okay, so do you think that you can just walk me through
而且它看起来像一面小手镜。虽然它绝对不是一面小手镜。它是一个小圆圈，旁边延伸出一条线，那条线上画着一个十字，因为我的血型是O型阳性。这是她血型的微型纹身，就在她的肋骨上，左臂正下方。好的，那么你觉得你能带我一步步
step-by-step the whole process of getting the tattoo? Oh, well, um... It was pretty straightforward. All of the kids whose parents had signed the little slip were taken, marched out of our classroom and down the hall. And yeah, this was in school. This happened in Lake County, Indiana. It was 1952 and my grandma was 16. And at the first station that you came to, they pricked your finger, and squeezed a little drop of blood onto a little card,
了解整个纹身的完整过程吗？哦，嗯……这其实很简单。所有父母签了那张小纸条的孩子都被带出教室，列队走出教室，顺着走廊往前走。对，这是在学校里。这发生在印第安纳州的莱克县。那是1952年，我奶奶16岁。当你走到第一个站点时，他们会刺破你的手指，把一小滴血挤到一张小卡片上，
and determined what your blood type was. And then you proceeded inside the library. Inside the library, Carol discovered a few makeshift privacy booths set up, and inside each booth and administrator, waiting with a tattoo gun, ready to draw a tiny O plus or A B or A minus on row upon row of waiting students, and always in the same place, on the torso, just under the left arm.
然后测出你的血型。接着你就可以走进图书馆了。在图书馆里，卡罗尔发现了几间临时搭建的隐私小隔间，每个隔间里都有一名管理员，手里拿着纹身枪，准备在成排等待的学生身上刺上一个微小的“O+”、“AB”或“A-”血型，而且位置总是相同的，都在躯干上、左臂的正下方。
It was sort of like an inkjet printer. It took seconds and it went, and that was it. My grandmother and the other students that day were part of an experimental program called Operation Tat Type. It was administered by the county, and the idea was simple, but also kind of terrifying. The goal of this was to make it easy to transfuse people who had been injured and who needed a blood transfusion in case of an atom bomb. At the age of 16, Liza's grandmother's body was permanently marked in anticipation of a nuclear catastrophe.
它有点像喷墨打印机。只需几秒钟，机器“嗡”的一声，就完成了。那天我的奶奶和其他学生一起参加了一个名为“纹身血型行动”的实验项目。该项目由县政府管理，其构想很简单，但也有点吓人。这个项目的目标是，在发生原子弹爆炸的情况下，能够轻松地为受伤并需要输血的人进行输血。在16岁时，丽莎奶奶的身体就被永久地做了标记，以防万一发生核灾难。
In 1952, the Cold War was in full swing, and the government was busy developing civil defense strategies. Things ordinary citizens could do to help protect the home front. And in this case, the thinking was that in the event of a Russian attack, the tattoos would make for quicker transfusions if children were incapacitated or did another blood type. But they would also have what they were calling a walking blood bank. So instead of having to extract blood from people, store it and keep it cool, you just have a cohort of potential donors walking around with their blood types written on their sides. And if you needed some A plus or AB minus or something, you would just check all these people and then when you found what you needed,
1952年，冷战正酣，政府正忙于制定民防战略——普通公民可以做些什么来协助保护本土。在这种情况下，当时的设想是，如果发生俄罗斯的袭击，如果孩子们失去行动能力或属于其他血型，这些纹身可以让输血变得更快。但他们还将拥有他们所谓的“流动的血库”。因此，不需要从人们身上抽血、储存并保持低温，你只需拥有一群潜在的捐献者，他们的血型就写在体侧，四处走动。如果你需要A型阳性、AB型阴性或其他血型，你只需要检查这些人，一旦找到你需要的，
you'd plug them into the person that needed the blood and do an immediate transfusion. You would just sort of like lift up somebody's arm. Mm-hmm. Yeah, yeah. I've got one here. This is what we need. You can maybe hear this from how she's talking, but for my grandma, getting this tattoo was not a big deal. Not at the time, not now. The way she tells it, it was a totally normal day, at least for a hoosier.
就把他们和需要血的人连起来，进行直接输血。你差不多就是把某人的胳膊抬起来。嗯嗯。对，对。我这里有一个。这就是我们需要的那种。也许从她的谈话中你能听出来，但对于我奶奶来说，纹身并不是什么大不了的事。当时不是，现在也不是。按她的说法，这完全是普通的一天，至少对一个印第安纳州人来说是这样。
This was Indiana, nobody gets all that excited. You know, about every little thing. You're studying line, you took your turn, you went back to class and finished your mathematics or whatever else you were doing at the time. But as trivial as it may have seemed at the time, Carol's tattoo was more than a weird little Cold War oddity. It was one of the smallest and most personal manifestations of a much larger idea that deeply influenced how the United States fought the Cold War, the concept of survivability. The idea that with enough canned food, shelters, fearlessness, and sometimes tattoos, the American
这里是印第安纳州，没有人会对每件小事都大惊小怪。你知道的，排好队，轮到你，然后回教室继续上数学课，或者做当时在做的其他事情。但尽管当时看起来微不足道，卡罗尔的纹身不仅仅是冷战时期的怪异小花絮。它是深刻影响美国冷战打法的一个更宏大理念的最小、最个人的体现之一——生存力概念。这一理念认为，只要有足够的罐头食品、避难所、无畏精神，有时再加上纹身，美国
people would be able to survive an atomic attack, and that it was only logical to prepare for it. There was a trail by the name of birth, and birth of Turtle was very alert. Today, if we remember anything about the idea of survivability, it's probably this. It's the Duck and Coverage Angle. The song that goes along with this grainy black and white film that was distributed by the Federal Civil Defense Administration. It shows a little hand-drawn turtle ducking under his shell. He's teaching kids to hide under their desks during a bomb.
人民将能够在一场原子袭击中生存下来，而且为之做准备是合情合理的。有一只名叫伯斯的乌龟，伯斯这只乌龟非常警觉。今天，如果我们对生存力这个概念还有什么记忆的话，那大概就是这个了。“蹲下并掩护”的桥段。这首歌曲伴随着联邦民防局分发的这段粗糙的黑白电影。画面显示一只手绘的小乌龟缩进壳里。它在教孩子们在炸弹袭来时躲在课桌底下。
People make fun of duck and cover a lot. It's considered the number one example of the kind of Cold War era propaganda that seems totally ridiculous now. Kitchie and absurd and sort of unimaginably naive. There are a lot of jokes made and I think ridicule of duck and cover. And even today, people joke about it and say you wouldn't be protected at all, it wouldn't make any difference. Susan Lindy is a historian of science at the University of Pennsylvania, who studies the Cold War. And she says that when we make fun of the usefulness of a tactic like decking cover,
人们经常拿“蹲下并掩护”开玩笑。它被认为是冷战时期宣传的第一大典范，现在看来完全荒谬、幼稚可笑，而且有着某种不可想象的幼稚。有很多人拿“蹲下并掩护”开玩笑，我认为也是在嘲弄它。甚至在今天，人们还拿它开玩笑，说你根本受不到保护，这起不到任何作用。宾夕法尼亚大学的历史学家苏珊·林迪专门研究冷战史。她说，当我们嘲笑“蹲下并掩护”这类战术的实用性时，
thinking it couldn't ever work, we're actually just wrong. Those films were, in fact, based on the individual experiences of persons who had been exposed at Hiroshima and Nagasaki. In September of 1945, just one month after the bombings of Hiroshima and Nagasaki, the US military sent a team of American doctors and geneticists to Japan to interview people who'd survived the attacks. They were looking to understand both the short and long-term effects of radiation.
认为它根本不管用，我们其实大错特错了。事实上，这些电影是以广岛和长崎亲历者的亲身经历为基础制作的。1945年9月，也就是广岛和长崎遭受原子弹轰炸仅仅一个月后，美军派遣了一支由美国医生和遗传学家组成的团队前往日本，采访袭击幸存者。他们希望借此了解辐射带来的短期和长期影响。
That program would eventually be named the Atomic Bomb Casualdee Commission, or the A-B-C-C. It would also prove to be highly controversial, because the researchers weren't there to treat the survivors. They were there to study them, and only to study them. And the reason to study the survivors was because they were surrogates for future American populations that would be subjected to exactly this kind of urban attack in a future nuclear war. It was American lives, not Japanese they were hoping to save, to understand who would survive and who would not when an American city was hit with an atomic bomb.
这个项目最终被命名为“原子弹伤害调查委员会”（简称ABCC）。这也引发了极大的争议，因为研究人员到那里并不是为了治疗幸存者，而是为了研究他们，而且仅仅是为了研究。研究幸存者的原因在于，他们是在未来核战争中将遭受完全这种城市袭击的未来美国人口的替代品。他们希望拯救的是美国人的生命，而不是日本人的生命，以此来了解当美国城市遭到原子弹袭击时，谁能幸存，谁会丧生。
So when the American scientists and physicians arrived in Hiroshima and Nagasaki, what they wanted to do first was to track down how many survivors there were. They were looking at lots of things, cancer rates, irregular pregnancies, heart disease, but also critically, they asked every survivor they interviewed. Where were you at the moment of the detonation? How close had they been? Because before the ABCC researchers arrived, the physicists who had developed the bomb had assumed
因此，当美国科学家和医生抵达广岛和长崎时，他们首先要做的是追踪有多少幸存者。他们考察了许多方面，如癌症发病率、异常妊娠、心脏病，但同样至关重要的是，他们询问了采访的每一位幸存者：爆炸发生时你在哪里？你离爆炸中心有多近？因为在ABCC研究人员到达之前，研制原子弹的物理学家曾假设，
that they wouldn't be finding survivors anywhere close to ground zero, what they called the hypocenter. But what became clear is that some people could be very close but weren't exposed to significant levels of radiation because they were shielded. And within about three blocks of the hypocenter at researchers discovered that people who had taken cover, even momentarily, didn't just survive the immediate blast, they seemed to be healthy. So there's a very famous story about Nagasaki, which involved young boys who were swimming, and they were diving off a cliff into a lake.
在极接近零点（即他们所称的“爆心”）的地方是找不到任何幸存者的。但显而易见的是，有些人虽然离得很近，却没有受到大量辐射，因为他们有掩护。在距离爆心大约三个街区范围内，研究人员发现，那些甚至只是短暂寻找了掩护的人，不仅在即时爆炸中幸存下来，而且似乎还很健康。关于长崎有一个非常著名的故事，讲的是几个正在游泳的男孩，他们从悬崖上跳水游向湖中。
And at the moment of detonation, five of them were upstanding up on the cliff and one of them had just hit the water and went underwater. And all five who were on that cliff were dead of leukemia by 1952. And the one who'd been underwater did not get sick. Anyone who had been behind even a tree was more likely to be alive five years later than someone who had been out in the open. And the logic of this is that the key exposure to radiation, the most important moment,
在爆炸发生的瞬间，他们中有五个人正站在悬崖上，而其中一人刚刚跳入水中潜入水下。到1952年，站在悬崖上的那五个人全部死于白血病，而那个在水下的人并没有生病。甚至只是在一棵树后面的人，在五年后活下来的可能性也比暴露在开阔地带的人要大。这里的逻辑在于，关键的辐射暴露、最重要的时刻，
lasts less than a second. It's not that there weren't other sources of radiation to be avoided, but what mattered most was being shielded at the moment of the blast. And during the blast wave that followed, it was the people who were standing up, who were most likely to be killed by shattering windows or falling debris. People who had been lying down when the blast wave hit, much more often survived. The lesson seemed clear. In the event of an atomic bomb, if you could stay low and stay shielded, in other words, if you ducked and covered, you might just be okay.
持续时间不到一秒。并不是说没有其他辐射源需要避开，但最重要的是在爆炸瞬间有掩体遮挡。在随后的冲击波中，站着的人最容易被破碎的窗户或坠落的 debris（碎片）夺去生命。当冲击波袭来时趴在地上的人，生还的机率要高得多。这个教训似乎很清楚：在原子弹爆炸的情况下，如果你能保持低姿势并有掩护，换句话说，如果你“蹲下并掩护”，你可能就会没事。
An American civil defense planter's head already began to wonder, if Duck and Cover could help the population of a city survive a nuclear attack, what else might work? They were studying things like psychology and group dynamics and infrastructure to see how society as a whole might hold up under a nuclear attack. And the civil defense policies that emerged from this research, all stressed that America could survive but only if everyone, not just the authorities but everyday citizens, did their part. With the knowledge of the first atomic explosions to guide us, our chances for survival
美国民防规划人员脑海中已经开始琢磨：如果“蹲下并掩护”能帮助城市居民在核袭击中幸存，还有什么方法可行？他们研究了心理学、群体动力学和基础设施等领域，以了解整个社会在核袭击下如何支撑下去。从这项研究中脱颖而出的民防政策全都强调，美国能够生存下来，但前提是每个人——不仅仅是当局，还有普通公民——都要尽到自己的责任。凭借第一次原子爆炸的知识指导我们，我们的生存机会
will be far better than those of the people of Hiroshima and Nagasaki. If we act on our knowledge and are prepared. Like practicing proper home maintenance. I am going to show you how protective measures can help guard your home against the heat effects of an atomic explosion. And air raid drills. Warning is flashed along the civil defense network, and an air raid target city preparedness gets as concrete a test as possible short of actual bombing. Even learning how to deal with irradiated soil.
将远远好于广岛和长崎的人民。只要我们根据这些知识采取行动并做好准备。比如练习正确的家居维护。我将向您展示如何通过防护措施保护您的家庭免受原子爆炸热效应的影响。还有空袭演习。警报通过民防网络闪烁发送，空袭目标城市的备战状态得到了除实战轰炸外最具体的测试。甚至学习如何处理受辐射的土壤。
For detailed information, get your free copy of Your Livestock Can Survive Fallout. And in Lake County, Indiana, they opted into a little pilot program to indicate their blood type with a tattoo. All predicated on the belief that, in the face of an atomic attack, a person and a society might just survive. And my grandma, she says she was pretty much on board. You don't have any particular memories of your first impressions of the program. Yeah, they were all positive. I thought this was a really good idea. She says, for one thing, it was a time when more people still trusted the government. Well, you were just coming off this big
有关详细信息，请免费获取您的《您的牲畜如何在放射性沉降物中生存》一书。而在印第安纳州莱克县，他们选择参加了一个小型试点项目，用纹身标出自己的血型。这一切都建立在一个信念之上：面对原子袭击，个人和社会或许都能生存下来。我奶奶说她对此非常赞同。你对这个项目的第一印象没有什么特别的记忆吗？是的，都很积极。我觉得这是一个非常好的主意。她说，一方面，那是一个人们仍然更信任政府的时期。嗯，你刚刚经历了一场巨大
war, which is impossibly complicated in all parts of the world. And yet somehow it had all come out all right. And so you felt that somebody was in charge that knew what he was doing. Plus, the place she lived in Northern Indiana was a huge railroad hub. And it was a possible target. She didn't know for sure whether the tattoos would help her survive an attack. But she also genuinely believed that they might.
的战争，这场战争在世界各地都复杂得不可思议。然而不知何故，一切都圆满解决了。因此你觉得有个掌权的人知道自己在做什么。另外，她居住的印第安纳州北部是一个巨大的铁路枢纽，也是一个潜在的目标。她并不确切知道纹身是否能帮她在袭击中活下来，但她也真诚地相信它们可能会。
They were worth getting. Because if people were injured and would not be able to be assisted because you didn't know their blood type is, well, that's a no-brainer. Just go ahead and write it, write it on them. Remember, this was a voluntary program. My grandmother signed up for it and so did most of her grade. She wanted to do her part to be prepared. Because who knows?
它们值得纹。因为如果有人受伤了，却因为不知道他们的血型而无法得到救助，嗯，那根本不用想。直接去把血型写在他们身上吧。记住，这是一个自愿的项目。我奶奶报名了，她班上的大多数人也报名了。她想尽自己的一份力做好准备。因为谁知道呢？
Who knows? You know, in all of the Japanese cities that were bombed, there had to be a next day. What do you do the next day? What do you do to save as many people as possible? The unthinkable thing, when it happens, you'll have to somehow react to it. When I really listened to my grandmother, this made sense to me. It made sense that people believe that the risk of an attack was real. and believe there was a way to be at least somewhat prepared. The problem is that not long after she got that tattoo, the premise behind it, survivability, stopped making sense.
谁知道呢？你知道，在所有遭受轰炸的日本城市里，必然会有第二天。第二天你该怎么做？为了拯救尽可能多的人，你能做些什么？当不可想象的事情发生时，你必须做出某种反应。当我真正倾听我奶奶的话时，我觉得这很有道理。人们相信袭击的风险是真实存在的，并且相信有办法至少做好某种程度的准备，这讲得通。问题在于，就在她纹身不久之后，其背后的前提——生存力，却不再讲得通了。
Even as children were learning to duck and cover and farmers were learning how to protect livestock from fallout, the very idea of what a nuclear war might look like was changing, and with it, our chances of survival. In 1950, just two years before Operation Tat-type, the Soviet Union had a grand total of five nuclear warheads. Five.
正当孩子们在学习“蹲下并掩护”、农民在学习如何保护牲畜免受放射性沉降物侵害时，核战争可能面貌的理念本身正在发生改变，随之改变的还有我们的生存几率。1950年，就在“纹身血型行动”推出仅仅两年前，苏联总共拥有五枚核弹头。五枚。
By 1960, they would have over 1600. Many of them thermonuclear weapons. Hydrogen bombs exponentially more powerful than the bombs dropped on Hiroshima and Nagasaki. By then, Susan Lindy thinks that civil defense tactics like the school tattoo program, they might still have been valuable in the event of a limited engagement, in which perhaps only a small number of cities were hit. So it's not that blood transfusion wouldn't have mattered at all. But in the event of a global thermonuclear war,
到1960年，他们将拥有超过1600枚。其中许多是热核武器。氢弹的威力比投在广岛和长崎的炸弹呈指数级强大。到那时，苏珊·林迪认为，诸如学校纹身项目之类的民防战术，在小规模交战（可能只有少数城市遭到袭击）的情况下可能仍然有价值。因此，并不是说输血完全不重要。但在全球热核战争的情况下，
where it's not just your city that's destroyed, but the entire infrastructure of the United States, you're not imagining a still functioning society outside of that city. You're imagining that there are no doctors to be rushed to the scene. Nobody can come from a neighboring city. And in that case, like, what are these children gonna do? Yeah, what are they gonna do? Still, government agencies like the Civil Defense
遭到摧毁的不仅仅是你的城市，而是整个美国的 инфраструктура（基础设施），你所想象的将不再是该城市以外依然运转的社会。你会发现没有医生可以赶赴现场，没有人能从邻近的城市赶来。在这种情况下，这些孩子会怎么做？对啊，他们会怎么做？尽管如此，像民防
Administration continued to promote the idea that the country could survive a full-throated nuclear attack in part because the gospel of survivability, however imaginary, still served other functions. Sure, imaginary things matter a lot, especially in propaganda. Because a lot of military and civil defense planners, they didn't just worry there would be a war. They were convinced war was coming. Department of Defense, the president, Congress, reached the conclusion that developing and stockpiling ever larger, ever more powerful nuclear weapons was absolutely crucial to the
管理局这样的政府机构继续宣称，国家能够在全面的核袭击中生存下来，部分原因在于生存力的信条（无论多么虚幻）仍然发挥着其他功能。当然，虚构的东西非常重要，尤其是在宣传中。因为许多军事和民防规划人员不仅担心会爆发战争，他们还确信战争即将来临。国防部、总统、国会得出结论，开发和囤积规模更大、威力更强的核武器绝对是至关重要的，
security and the future survival of the United States. Which is why, by 1960, the same year the Soviet nuclear arsenal topped 1,600 warheads, the United States had more than 18,000. And those weapons were controversial, almost from the beginning. In one week in June, demonstrations took place in more than a dozen countries and at 50 locations throughout the United States. There were always protests. Within 24 hours of the dropping of the bomb, there were critics all over the world
关乎美国的国家安全和未来生存。正因如此，到1960年，也就是苏联核武库突破1600枚核弹头的同年，美国拥有的核弹头已超过1.8万枚。这些武器几乎从一开始就充满争议。6月的一周内，十几个国家和美国境内的50个地点爆发了示威游行。抗议活动从未间断。在原子弹投下后24小时内，世界各地就出现了批评声音，
saying that the United States should not have used it. If this keeps up, then where does it stop? Do we live under this sort of domicile forever? And there were the allotions who said this is an immoral form of warfare. That what's happening here is immoral and that we, in faith, must resist it. And that made the logic of survivability doubly useful. Things like lessons in school, and evacuation we, in faith, must resist it. And that made the logic of survivability doubly useful.
称美国根本不该使用它。如果这种情况继续下去，那何时是个头？难道我们要永远生活在这样的统治之下吗？还有一些和平主义者说，这是一种不道德的战争形式。这里发生的事情是不道德的，我们出于信仰必须予以抵制。这使得生存力的逻辑具有了双倍的实用性。学校里的课程、疏散演习……我们出于信仰必须予以抵制。这使得生存力的逻辑具有了双倍的实用性。
Things like lessons in school, and evacuation drills, and tattoos. The advice is increasing the acceptability of nuclear weapons, and increasing public belief in the idea that even if a nuclear war came, there would be strategies that would permit those who were properly prepared to survive. And did it work? Like, did people feel less scared? I think that some people did, maybe most people, because when you look at surveys of people in the 50s about nuclear weapons, people believe that they're necessary.
学校里的课程、疏散演习以及纹身，这些建议提高了人们对核武器的接受度，增强了公众的一种信念：即便是核战争来临，也会有策略让那些做好充分准备的人存活下来。这真的管用吗？人们真的觉得没那么害怕了吗？我想有些人是这样的，也许大部分人都是，因为当你查看50年代人们对核武器的调查时，人们认为它们是必要的。
And if you believe it's necessary, then you have to believe that it's also practical, that it's not insane. You have to believe it's not insane. The year that my grandma got her tattoo, 15,000 other late county residents also got their blood type checked through the tattoo- Tat typing program.
如果你认为它是必要的，那么你必然也会认为它是切合实际的、并非疯狂的。你必须相信它不是疯狂的。我奶奶纹身的那一年，莱克县还有15,000名居民通过“纹身血型”项目检查了他们的血型。
Finger-priced, drop a blood on the card. Two-thirds of those people opted for a tattoo. But Operation Tat Type didn't go far outside Lake County. Despite all the survivability fervor, it never made it beyond the pilot program. When I touched on my grandma though, I can kind of hear it. The thing Lindy talks about, about the psychological impact of programs like this. Did getting a tattoo make you feel safer? Yes, I guess so. I thought that I had done the thing that was available to do
扎一下手指，把血滴在卡片上。其中三分之二的人选择纹身。但“纹身血型行动”并没有推广到莱克县以外的地方。尽管有各种生存狂热，但它从未超越试点项目阶段。不过，当我与奶奶交谈时，我多少能体会到林迪所说的那些此类项目的心理影响。纹身后你觉得更安全了吗？是的，我想是的。我觉得我已经做了力所能及的事，
to help in case of a total disaster. I thought I had done the right thing. But maybe more importantly, it was just doing something that made her feel better. a total disaster. I thought I had done the right thing. But maybe more importantly, it was just doing something that made her feel better. It was hard to imagine the bigger picture. No, no, I didn't dwell on all of that. I didn't envision myself lying there and doctors coming up and throwing up my arm and saying, aha, oh plus, transfuse this child with a plus blood, you know, I never played that all out in my mind. She says she was way too busy.
以便在全面灾难发生时提供帮助。我觉得我做对了。但或许更重要的是，这只是一件让她感觉好一点的事。全面灾难。我觉得我做对了。但或许更重要的是，这只是一件让她感觉好一点的事。很难去想象宏大的全局。不，不，我没有纠结于所有这些。我没有设想自己躺在那里，医生冲过来掀起我的胳膊说：“啊哈，O型阳性，给这个孩子输O型阳性血。”你知道，我从来没有在脑海里把这一切演练过。她说她当时忙得不可开交。
She was talking with her friends about boys or what they were going to do over the weekend. Daily life, the life she was living was much more attractive. Otherwise, we'd go crazy if we had to deal intensively with all of these terrible threats. It's a certain amount of stuff. I can't think about that. You just gotta keep going and do other things. I think that's one of the great capacities we have. Today, the legacy of survivability is hidden behind a new series of titles, acronyms, and other
她正和朋友们谈论男孩，或者周末要做什么。日常生活，她正在过的那种生活要迷人得多。否则，如果我们必须深入应对所有这些可怕的威胁，我们就会发疯。总得有个限度。我不能去想那些。你只能继续前进，做别的事情。我认为这是我们拥有的最伟大的能力之一。如今，生存力的遗产被隐藏在一系列新的头衔、缩略词和其他
obfuscating symbols. The Atomic Bomb Caterlary Commission, which studied the effects of the atomic bomb in Hiroshima and Nagasaki, eventually became the Radiation Effects Research Foundation. A joint American Japanese venture that has continued to study the long-term effects on the survivors of the bomb and their children nearly 75 years later. The Federal Civil Defense Administration, after several name changes, was combined with various other agencies to form FEMA in 1978.
混淆视听的符号背后。曾研究广岛和长崎原子弹爆炸影响的“原子弹伤害调查委员会”，后来演变成了“放射线影响研究所”。这是一个美日合资机构，在近75年后的今天，它仍在继续研究原子弹幸存者及其子女所受的长期影响。联邦民防管理局在经历了几次更名后，于1978年与其它几个机构合并成了联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）。
Its strategies have been adapted to deal with hurricanes, earthquakes, and, yes, possible nuclear attacks. And then there's the tiny legacy of survivability inked on the torso of Carol Fischler, just under her left arm. A faded tattoo that says, oh, positive, but looks like a picture of a little hand mirror. Special thanks to professors Tracy Davis and Ann Laman at Northwestern University whose voices we did not get to include but who provided us with invaluable information during our research for this story.
它的策略已被调整用于应对飓风、地震，当然还有可能的核袭击。然后，就是留在卡罗尔·菲施勒躯干上左臂下方那个微小的生存力遗产。一个褪色的纹身，上面写着“O型阳性”，但看起来像一幅小手镜的图片。特别感谢西北大学的特雷西·戴维斯（Tracy Davis）教授和安·拉曼（Ann Laman）教授，我们在制作这个故事的研究过程中获得了他们提供的宝贵信息，虽然未能将他们的声音收录其中。
Up next, Joe Rosenberg and I play global thermonuclear war. Stay with us. Okay, so Roman, do you remember the movie War Games? I absolutely remember the movie War Games. It's a big deal when I was kid. Oh yeah, and it's aged. I should just side note, it's aged incredibly well. Yeah, I don't doubt it. For those who don't know it or don't remember,
接下来，乔·罗斯伯格（Joe Rosenberg）和我将进行一场全球热核战争游戏。请继续收听。好了，罗曼，你还记得电影《战争游戏》吗？我当然记得《战争游戏》这部电影。我小时候这可是个大片。哦，对，而且它经久不衰。顺便说一句，它经久不衰得令人难以置信。是的，我对此毫不怀疑。对于那些不知道或者不记得这部电影的人来说，
it's kind of one of those classic movies from the 80s, where a teenager somehow single-handedly takes on the military industrial complex. Exactly. There's an entire subgenre and obviously, uh, stranger things owes a lot to it. Totally. Anyways, in this case, the teenager is played by a young Matthew Broderick, a pre-fair spieler, by the way, who hacks into this quasi-senshin computer mainframe that runs NORAD. And once he's in, this computer starts talking to him.
它有点像80年代的经典电影之一，讲的是一个青少年不知怎的单枪匹马对抗军工复合体。没错。这是一个完整的亚文化类型，显然，《怪奇物语》很大程度上借鉴了它。完全是这样。无论如何，在这部电影中，青少年由年轻的马修·布罗德里克（Matthew Broderick，顺便说一句，当时还不是费尔·斯皮尔）饰演，他黑入了运行北美防空司令部（NORAD）的这种准有意识的计算机大型机。一旦他进去了，这台计算机就开始跟他对话。
And it says, you know, Cree Danes, would you like to play a game? And this list of simulated games the computer likes to play pops up. And one of them is called Global Thermonuclear War. Right. And Broderick's character is, you know, teenager. He's teenager he's like hell yes I want to play the only option right yeah I want to play global thermo nuclear war but the computer tries to talk him out of it and is like wouldn't you prefer maybe I'll just say I'm not gonna try do it okay okay wouldn't you prefer a nice game of chess love it and broader is like no no way global thermo nuclear war and eventuallyoric is like, uh, no. No way. Global thermonuclear war.
它说：“你知道的，约书亚，你想玩个游戏吗？”接着弹出了计算机喜欢玩的模拟游戏列表。其中一个叫做“全球热核战争”。没错。布罗德里克的角色是个青少年，他觉得太棒了，我想玩，唯一的选项对吧？对，我想玩全球热核战争。但计算机试图劝他放弃，并说：“你难道不更倾向于……好吧，我不会试图去模仿它，好吧，好吧。你难道不想下一盘精彩的棋吗？我喜欢。”布罗德里克却说：“不，绝不。全球热核战争。”最终，计算机说：“好吧。突然间，布罗德里克面对着这样一个游戏：一张世界地图摆在他面前。
And eventually the computer is like, fine. And suddenly, the Brotoric is presented with this game where the map of the world is laid out before him. And he can start dropping bombs on cities and see what happens. And of course, things go awry from there, you know, hilarity and soons. I won't spoil the movie for anyone. But when I first saw Wargames when I was all of, I don't know, 10 years old, I kept thinking, man, why can't I play a game called Global Thermonucleure War? You know, to my 10 year old brain, that sounded wonderful.
他可以开始向城市投掷炸弹，看看会发生什么。当然，从那以后事情就出了岔子，你知道的，爆笑连连。我不会剧透电影。但当我第一次看到《战争游戏》时，当时我差不多，嗯，10岁左右，我一直在想：天哪，为什么我不能玩一个叫“全球热核战争”的游戏？你知道，在我10岁的大脑里，听起来这太棒了。
Absolutely. Well, here's the thing. In doing some of the research for this story 26 years later I kind of sort of found it nice. It's this online simulator It's called NukeMap in which you can simulate the detonation of the nuclear weapon of your choice at any spot on the globe And you get to see what happens. Okay, so let's try it out. What's the address I need to go to? Just Google and NukeMap and it's usually the first thing that comes up. NukeMap by Alex Willarsene. Is that right? Yeah, correct.
绝对如此。嗯，是这样的。在为这个故事做一些研究时，26年后的我，差不多算是找到了它。这是一个名为“核弹地图”（NukeMap）的在线模拟器，你可以在其中模拟在地球上的任何地点引爆你选择的核武器，并能看到会发生什么。好吧，那我们来试试吧。我需要访问哪个网址？直接在谷歌上搜索“NukeMap”，通常弹出的第一个就是。亚历克斯·韦勒斯坦（Alex Wellerstein）制作的NukeMap。是这样吗？是的，没错。
Oh, here we go. Oh yeah. Drag the marker wherever you want it, like to hit the target, or you can like try a preset. Right, so you first get to choose which city it is, you'd like to destroy. Okay. You can place the marker anywhere, but there's, you'll see there's like a handy drop-down menu. Do you have a crapper? Oh, go right to San Francisco. Okay. You can place the marker anywhere, but you'll see there's like a handy drop down menu. Do you have a crapper?
哦，我们来啦。哦，对。把标记拖到你想要的任何地方，比如击中目标，或者你可以尝试预设。没错，所以你首先得选择你想要摧毁的城市。好的。你可以把标记放在任何地方，但你会看到有一个很方便的下拉菜单。你有想毁灭的吗？哦，直接去旧金山吧。好的。你可以把标记放在任何地方，但你会看到有一个很方便的下拉菜单。你有想毁灭的吗？
We'll go right to San Francisco. Okay. So you want to nuke yourself. Well, you know, I think it's only fair. I mean, I actually did the exact same thing. As far as I can tell, everyone I've showed this to you, like they always immediately either nuke themselves or New York. Right.
我们接下来去奥克兰。好的。好吧，输入当量。这里有一个预设的千吨级炸弹类型供你尝试。有许多不同的武器，历史上真正的武器。你可以从实际的美俄武库中进行选择。你可以选择非常微小的、可以从大炮发射的20吨裂变武器，也可以选择有史以来引爆过的最大武器——也就是俄罗斯人曾经引爆过的这个50万吨（注：原文50 megatons应为5000万吨/50兆吨）的氢弹怪兽。
We'll do Oakland next. Okay. Okay. So, enter the yield. There's a preset of the type of kiloton bomb you can try. A lot of different weapons, real weapons from history. You can choose from the actual US and Russian arsenals. You can choose really tiny, you know, 20 ton vision weapons that can be shot from a cannon to like the largest ever detonated, which is this 50 megaton hydrogen monster that the
那么，你想选哪个？好吧，让我们选那个最大的吧。这就是“沙皇炸弹”，苏联测试过的最大炸弹，当量为50兆吨。好的，我们选择那个。好的，基本选项，爆高，空中爆炸或地面爆炸。空中爆炸是指它在城市上空的某个高度爆炸。对。
Russians detonated this one time. So, like, which do you want to choose? Well, let's, you know, let's go for the big one. So this is the Sarbama, largest USSR bomb tested at 50 megatons. Okay, we'll select that. Okay, basic options, height of burst, air burst or surface. So air burst is, you know, like it explodes above the city at some point. Yeah.
某种高度。好的，你选择了空中爆炸，选择了50兆吨。它即将被投放在差不多马克街的正上方。就在格雷罗街和多洛雷斯街之间的第21街。没错。不管怎样，这些都不重要了，因为这是一个巨大的冲击波。现在有一个又大又漂亮的红色按钮，上面写着“引爆”。
Something. Okay. And so you've chosen air burst, you've chosen 50 megatons. It's about to be dropped pretty much right on Market Street. It's on 21st between Guerrero and Dolores. Right. Not that any of this is going to matter because it's a huge wall. So now there's a big beautiful red button that says detonate.
我们开始吧。好的。现在，它显示估计死亡人数为150万人，这完全不是开玩笑的。它有一个全红的内部爆破半径。没错。然后是一个一直延伸到安提奇的外层爆破半径。接着，我猜这就像是一个放射性云团，一直延伸到萨克拉门托以外。
Let's do it. All right. Oh. Right now, it's totally not the estimated fatalities at 1.5 million people. It has this inner blast radius that's all red. Right. And then an outer blast radius that reaches all the way to anyach. And then a, I guess this is like a radioactive cloud that reaches well past Sacramento.
太疯狂了。实际上，对于像这样的大炸弹，我的意思是，你可以看到外面的红圈，我相信，比如，就是三度烧伤。没错。冲击波几乎会摧毁整个湾区。是的。这有点像你预料的那样，对吧？
Yeah. It's crazy. And actually with these big bombs like this, I mean, actually you can see that outer red ring is, I believe, like, is, you know, third degree burns. Yeah. Shockwave is pretty much going to take out the entire Bay area. Yeah. It's kind of like what you expected, right?
完全是这样。这就是我们认为核战争应有的样子。这简直是彻底的毁灭。甚至都不需要离得很近。中央山谷的人们或许还能安然无恙，但我们在奥克兰——旧金山湾正对面的地方——绝对死定了。没错。
Totally. This is what we think of nuclear war as looking like. It's just total devastation. Like you don't even need to be close. People in the central valley might be okay, but we hear in Oakland right across the bay from SF, we're definitely dead. Right.
但这个工具有趣且真正有价值的地方在于，如果你稍微改变一下参数。所以我希望你运行完全相同的模拟。但这次我希望你选择名为“胖子”的炸弹。这是美国投在长崎的炸弹。好的，“胖子”。这是20千吨。我们开始吧，引爆！
But where this gets interesting and actually valuable is if you shift things up just a bit. So I want you to run the exact same simulation. But this time I want you to choose the bomb called Fat Man. This was the bomb the United States dropped on Nagasaki Okay fat man. This is 20 kilotons. Here we go detonate
好吧，旧金山仍然有麻烦，但你谈论的是估计有7万人的死亡人数，而且空气冲击波半径实际上只延伸到日落区的第19大道。这就是我第一次使用时让我震惊的地方。我们认为具有毁灭性的这些原始炸弹确实具有毁灭性，但与氢弹相比，
All right, okay San Francisco is in trouble still, but you're talking about 70,000 estimated fatalities and the talking about 70,000 estimated fatalities and the air blast radius, it really reaches only to 19th Avenue to the sunset. That's what I first use, that's what kind of shock me. These original bombs that we think of as these devastating weapons, they are devastating, but compared to the hydrogen weapons,
它们小得惊人。甚至如果你计算一下会打破窗户的冲击波，那个冲击波甚至都不到达奥克兰。它甚至都波及不到我们。有趣的是，你开始意识到这些较小的、较旧的武器，比如广岛炸弹、长崎炸弹，它们摧毁了城市中心的一大块地方。但它仅仅是这一块。
they're kind of shockingly small. And even if you calculate the shock wave that would break windows, that shockwave doesn't even reach Oakland. It doesn't even reach us. It's interesting because what you start to realize is that these smaller, older weapons, like the Hiroshima bomb, like the Nagasaki bomb, they take out this big chunk from the center of a city. But it's just this chunk.
这一块之外的一切基本上都完好无损。我们需要把这一点放在语境中来看，并指出就生命损失而言，这仍然是一场难以置信的灾难。哦，完全是这样，是的。这个模拟并不应该淡化那些炸弹极其恐怖并夺去了很多人命这一事实。但当你看到一些最大核武器的潜力与这些较小的核武器相比时，你会意识到生存力的这种逻辑确实是成立的。
Everything outside the chunk is kind of intact. And we need to put this in context and point out that in terms of lives lost. This is still an incredible catastrophe. Oh, totally, yeah. This simulation shouldn't minimize the idea that those bombs are horrible, and they killed a lot of people. But when you see what some of the largest nuclear weapons,
对的。所以，是的，我认为这确实有助于证明我一直听到的这种说法，正如我们在故事中所说的那样：氢核武器的威力呈指数级大于常规核武器。但这对我来说并没有什么实际意义。我当时想：氢弹、常规武器，都一样。它们都很糟糕。但现实并非如此，破坏量之间存在着几乎是存在主义的差异。正如丽莎的奶奶所说，是否会有第二天。事实证明，这对于我们如何思考
the potential of them, and these smaller ones, you realize that this logic of survivability really is intact. Right. Right. So yeah, I think it's really helps demonstrate this thing that I'd always heard, just like we say in the story, that hydrogen nuclear weapons are exponentially more powerful than conventional nuclear weapons. But that didn't really mean anything to me. I was like hydrogen, conventional, whatever. They're all bad. But in reality, no, there is an almost existential difference in the amount of destruction. And as Liza's grandmother puts it, whether there's going to be a next day or not. And it turns out that this actually has really profound consequences for how we think
当今的核威胁具有非常深远的影响。因为人们对炸弹持彻底的宿命论态度。他们会说：“还能怎么办呢？无能为力。这不是我能对付的，这不是我能做的事。”这就是该网站的创建者亚历克斯·韦勒斯坦（Alex Wellerstein）。他是史蒂文斯理工学院的核史教授，也是一个名为“重塑民防”项目的成员。
about nuclear threats in the present day. Because people get real fatalistic about the bomb. They say things like, well, what could you do? There's nothing to do. It's not something I can deal with. It's not something I can do. So this is the Sized Creator, Alex Wellerstein. He's a professor of nuclear history at the Stevens Institute of Technology and also part
他表示，他搭建NukeMap网站的原因之一是，我们基本上仍然抱持着冷战后期的那种模式，将核战争视为一种全球性的存在主义威胁。你知道，为什么还要去想它呢？因为如果它发生了，我们都死定了。这就像得了某种罕见疾病一样。所以，你知道的，为什么还要担心呢？这就成了彻底躺平的借口。
of a project called reinventing civil defense. And he says that one reason he built the Nuke map site is that we're still basically holding on to this late Cold War model of seeing nuclear war as this global existential threat. You know, why bother thinking about it? Because if it happens, we're all dead. It's like getting a rare disease. So, you know, like, why worry? And that becomes the excuse to totally check out.
这不仅在发生意外时选择躺平，而且在将其视为国家政策问题时也选择躺平。在条约问题上躺平，在总统被允许做什么等问题上躺平。我真的希望人们不要躺平。我认为最好的方法是让他们更现实地思考这个问题。那么在这种情况下，什么才是现实的呢？
And it's not just checking out if there's something happened to them, but it's checking out for it being like a national policy issue. It's checking out on treaties, checking out on, you know, what the president's allowed to do, that kind of thing. And I'd really like people not to check out. And I think the best way to do it is to get them to think about this more realistically. And so what is realistic in this case?
在当前的地缘政治气候下，不太可能发生、也不现实的情况是俄罗斯甚至中国用成千上万枚巨大的弹头消灭美国和半个地球，尽管这正是大多数人最倾向于联想到的情景。他们很难转变为：不，不，不，我们谈论的是来自朝鲜的两三次引爆。整个国家不会因此死光。然后，如果你这么想，就会有点压力，也许本该如此，对吧？
What's not particularly likely, what's not realistic in the current geopolitical climate is Russia or even China obliterating the United States and half the world with thousands of gigantic warheads, even though that's the scenario that most people like to gravitate towards. They have a hard time shifting into, no, no, no, we're talking about two or three detonations from North Korea. Nation is not going to be dead. And then if you do that, it is a little stressful, then maybe it should be, right?
因为你突然发现：哦，我们本该有个计划的。这就是NukeMap派上用场的地方，因为它确实有助于传达威胁的正确规模，如果你选择（你知道的）朝鲜规模的弹头——这也是选项之一，你会发现它比广岛炸弹大，但与这些大型氢弹造成的破坏相比，它在广岛的破坏程度方面仍然要接近得多。好吧。所以我们仍然处于“会有第二天”的领地，
Because you suddenly see it like, oh, we should have a plan. And this is where NukeMap comes in, because it really helps convey the proper size of the threat, because if you select for, you know, a North Korean size warhead, and that is one of the options, you'll see it is larger than the Hiroshima bomb, but still much, much closer Hiroshima in terms of the kind of damage it does compared to these large hydrogen weapons. Okay. So we're still in the, there will be a next day territory,
因此需要有一个计划。这完全说得通。鉴于此，计划是什么呢？在亚历克斯看来，最重要的事情是，既然我们再次面临这些有限核战争方案的可能性，作为一种文化，我们需要重新学习民防。事实上，你现在就能在FEMA的网站上找到民防战术，
hence the need for a plan. That totally makes sense. So given this, what is the plan? Well, the big thing in Alex's mind is that now that we are once again presented with the possibility of these limited nuclear scenarios, we, as a culture, need to relearn civil defense. And in fact, there are civil defense tactics
比如一旦发生核袭击该怎么办，但亚历克斯通过“重塑民防”项目所做的工作，部分关于我们如何以某种方式积极传播这些信息，让普通人不会斜眼相看、感到恐慌，或者将其视为老大哥宣传、将核武器正常化，因为他认为这些
you can find on the FEMA website, like right now, in case of a nuclear attack, but Alex's work with the re-inventing civil defense project is in part about how we could maybe actively disseminate this information in a way that everyday people won't look at scant-atty, there's like kind of panic inducing or as big brother propaganda that's normalizing nuclear weapons because he thinks that these
民防战术可以拯救生命。因此，他希望看到回归的重大事项之一——我和他在这点上不谋而合——就是“蹲下并掩护”。你可以用一种非常粗暴的方式这样去想：如果你离武器真的太近，那么你做什么都无济于事，一切都会在转瞬间结束。如果你离武器真的非常远，你会说：“刚才那是什么？”无论你做什么都无所谓，因为你已经脱离了射程范围。
civil defense tactics could save lives. And so one of the big things he'd like to see come back, and I'm with him on this by the way, is ducking cover. You can think of it in a very crude way this way. If you're really too close to the weapon, then nothing you do is going to matter. And it's going to be over very fast. If you're really far away from the weapon, then nothing you do is going to matter, and it's going to be over very fast. If you're really far away from the weapon, you're going to say, what was that? And it's not going to matter what you do because you're outside the range.
民防战术可以挽救生命。因此，他希望恢复的一件大事——顺便说一句，我也赞同他的看法——就是“就地掩蔽”。你可以用非常粗略的方式这样理解：如果你离武器实在太近，那么你做什么都无济于事，而且一切都会迅速结束。如果你离武器非常远，那么你也不会受到太大影响。如果你离武器真的很远，你可能会问，刚刚那是什么？无论你做什么都无关紧要，因为你已经处于杀伤范围之外了。
And then there's sort of an in-between range where ducking and covering in some situations is exactly the right thing to do. And this is for all the reasons that were laid out in the main story, which is avoiding direct exposure to radiation and heat protecting yourself from structural damage and shattering windows, which you can see on these nuke map simulations of what a North Korean-sized weapon would do. Even if you're relatively close to the epicenter, you're much more likely to be in the zone of the shockwave, or at least the blast, you're most likely not going to be in the all-consuming
还有一种居中的情况，在某些情况下，就地掩蔽（趴下并护住头部）绝对是正确的做法。这出于主报道中列出的所有原因，即避免直接暴露于辐射和热辐射中，保护自己免受结构损坏和碎裂玻璃的伤害。你可以从这些核地图模拟中看到朝鲜规模的武器会造成什么影响。即使你离震中相对较近，你也更有可能处于冲击波区域，或者至少是爆炸区域，你最不可能处于那个吞噬一切的
fireball. But maybe the biggest takeaway from the nukeMap simulator is what it can teach you about dealing with fallout. Because in this scenario where we survive from over here in our, you know, the cushy confines of Oakland, actually we're not out of the woods. The prevailing winds come this way, so we definitely have to deal with fallout. And in fact, that's what presents the most danger to the most people in these scenarios with these smaller weapons. And so Alex just a few weeks ago he added this feature which is kind of like Google Street view. You can drop this little marker anywhere on the map and tell it whether you're indoors or outdoors or in a basement and it will basically tell you how okay you'll be.
火球之中。但从核地图模拟器中获得的最大收获，也许是它能教你如何应对放射性沉降物。因为在这种情况下，我们在奥克兰舒适的环境中幸存下来，其实我们并没有脱离危险。主导风向是这样的，所以我们绝对必须应对沉降物。事实上，在这些使用较小武器的场景中，这才是对最多的人构成最大危险的事情。所以亚历克斯在几周前添加了这个功能，它有点像谷歌街景。你可以把这个小标记放在地图上的任何地方，并告诉它是室内、室外还是地下室，它基本上会告诉你你的情况会有多好。
Because you can see very starkly, oh, if I'm stuck on the freeway, I'm going to absorb this much radiation in this case. However, if I had just stayed at home, then that cuts it down to this much. And if I go into a basement or someplace bigger, wow, it's like basically nothing at all. So it's cool. So it's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's
因为你可以非常鲜明地看到，哦，如果我被困在高速公路上，在这种情况下我将吸收这么多辐射。然而，如果我只是呆在家里，那么辐射量就会降到这么多。如果我去地下室或某个更大的地方，哇，基本上什么都没有了。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这很酷。所以这
cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's It's cool. It's cool. It's cool. It's cool Right, and you should almost always shelter in place. Good. The old tagline is get inside, stay inside. Because even just being inside a house will likely save your life if you're dealing with fallout. But in this case, it turns out there are limits to what kind of advice. However, well backed up by data and nuke map, human beings are willing to accept, particularly
很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。很酷。对的，而且你几乎总是应该就地避难。好。旧的口号是：进去，待在里面。因为如果你在应对沉降物，哪怕只是待在房子里也很有可能会救你的命。但在这个由数据和核地图很好地支持的案例中，人们愿意接受的建议类型事实上有其局限性，特别是
when it comes to advice for fallout safety. Some of our researchers in that this communication has not gone that well. And in fact, my colleagues asked people, they actually told them what the right thing to do is, and then asked them what they would do, and a lot of them were like, I could get my kids. Yeah, if there was a bomb went off or a fire happened, where it's like so much better for kids to just stay in school where they are, and my impulse would be to run right to them. It's totally true. So you just ignore this and... I don't know if I would've told you.
当涉及到防辐射建议时。我们的一些研究人员认为这种沟通并不顺利。事实上，我的同事问过人们，他们实际上告诉了他们什么是正确的事情要做，然后问他们会怎么做，其中许多人就像，我可以去接我的孩子。是的，如果发生了一颗炸弹爆炸或火灾，这就好比让孩子们留在学校里要好得多，而我的冲动就是直接向他们跑去。这完全是真的。所以你只要忽略这个，然后……我不知道我是否会告诉你。
What if, yeah, what if that meant they didn't have a father the next day? Well, I mean, I'd rather them live than me, that's for sure. But it would be really hard to fight the impulse to not run to them no matter what I knew in terms of common sense approach. I guess I can't be one to judge,
如果，是的，如果这意味着第二天他们没有父亲呢？嗯，我的意思是，我宁愿他们活着，我死，那是肯定的。但是，无论我从常识的角度知道什么，要对抗不顾一切向他们跑去的冲动，将会是非常困难的。我想我不能算是一个评判者，
because I'd like to believe that I would overcome that paternal instinct, but maybe once I have children. That's all the children are going to go right out the way. You never know. But anyway, so let this be a lesson for everyone. The next time a computer program, like NukeMap, asks you if you want to play Global Thermonuclear War, you should say yes. Do it, absolutely. Nuke You should say yes. Do it. Absolutely.
因为我很想相信我会克服那种父性本能，但也许一旦我有了孩子。所有的孩子都会走到路边。你永远不知道。但无论如何，让这成为对大家的教训。下一次，当像NukeMap这样的计算机程序问你是否想玩全球热核战争时，你应该说是。去做吧，绝对的。核弹 你应该说是。去做吧。绝对的。
Newt yourself. It's how it goes. And it's actually the reason for a thing to do. Play out the simulation. You might learn something. All right. Thanks, Joe. Thank you. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Liza Yeager and edited by Joe Rosenberg.
引爆你自己。事情就是这样。这其实是一件值得去做的事。把模拟过程运行一遍。你可能会学到一些东西。好的。谢谢，乔。谢谢。本周的《百分之九十九隐形》由丽莎·耶格尔（Liza Yeager）制作，乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）编辑。
Mix and Tech Production by Sheree Fusef, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kirk Cole-Stat is the digital director. The rest of the team is senior editor Delaney Hall, Avery Trouffman, and Mip Fitzgerald Vivian Lee, Teran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row, in Beautiful, Downtown, Oakland, California. We are a proud member of Radio Topia from PRX, a collection of fiercely independent and fascinating podcasts. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
混音和技术制作由雪莉·福瑟夫（Sheree Fusef）负责，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的高级制作人，柯克·科尔-斯塔特（Kirk Cole-Stat）是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括高级编辑德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Trouffman）以及米普·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、特兰·马扎（Teran Mazza）和我——罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心广播街。我们很自豪能够成为来自 PRX 的 Radiotopia 的一员，这是一个由极具独立精神和迷人播客组成的合集。请在 radiotopia.fm 上找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到这个节目并加入关于节目的讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Marsars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But you're always welcome to shelter at our place at 99PI.org. Radio til the end. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在推特上@我，账号是Roman Marsars，也可以@节目，账号是99PI org。我们也在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上。但随时欢迎你在我们的网站 99PI.org 避难。广播直到最后。来自 PRX。目前这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。